oh you got their cheese daddy cheese
plate well there's some good cheese and
some batches on there right that's
really good is it nice man you're you're
you're very you look like a skater
you're dressed you're very dusty looking
this is an off-white
that's not an off-black i'm
oh is that all expensive is that
expensive gear
probably more than oh
don't be obnoxious that what do you mean
you don't know
the last thing i heard
before this was mine yeah was
will you wear this
please
i'll sit and pay for it
don't stick your wow
little thing like that [ __ ] your
offensive listen
just i asked you the best piece of
cheese on there chris
can you wrap in the salami for me daddy
sure i will
so
the last thing i heard don't eat it in
an annoying won't
i last thing you heard no i won't
because i'm a man of my word
yeah
last thing i heard yeah
before i wore this yeah the first time
was yeah
will you wear this please
that is so
funny so i don't know how much it is
shoot with your mouth closed you [ __ ]
it's
you're so obnoxious dude
so i guess somebody wanted you to wear
it because oh yeah then we get the brown
down
yeah
do you know what they said after i put
it on
what man the first thing i heard
yeah when this was
in my possession yeah
are you gonna rap on those first or what
dude chris
don't no i know but all right don't eat
that i'm saying the first thing i heard
when this was in
my possession what
thank you
he's so stupid
chris
so gross you know there are cameras on
you you can't
eat like that
why are you putting it all the way in
the back of your mouth you're not a
[ __ ] snake you're not a snake you
have teeth you can you don't have to
put it all the way
it's hitting the gang of yours you're a
doppelganger whatever [ __ ] that thing's
called
oh man i hate when people eat slow like
that
well you don't want me wrapping yours
now